we never really know what goes on in
people's minds or what they do right
the White Lotus relationship rumors
continue on a recent episode of Watch
What Happens live with Andy Cohen guest
Megan Faye was put on the spot by a
cheeky question from a viewer yes Megan
who plays Daphne Sullivan on season two
of the hit HBO show finally addressed
those romance rumors with her co-star
Leo Woodall who plays Jack Megan thank
you is there any truth to the rumor that
you might be dating in White Lotus
co-star Leo what all that's the rumor
that you and the uncle [ __ ] are dating
thankfully Megan thought the question
was amusing but capture answer titles
oh I don't kiss and tell come on guys it
would be delicious it would be delicious
however and he wasn't letting her off
that easy pushing for more we would all
love it you would yeah for you I'll say
sure
because you're wanting me to say it so I
said it now rumors about the para have
been swirling online since a number of
exchanges were caught on Instagram by
eagle-eyed fans first it was Megan who
commented on a post from Leo where he
was sharing behind the scenes pictures
from set she wrote I love you I love
these I love you and on a post Megan
shared of her shoot with luk magazine
she included the caption I love the UK
leading the UK native Woodall to respond
in the comments writing UK Loves You
Back
now most recently Megan shared another
collection of throwback picks back in
December with one snap capturing the two
actors cozied up while filming the White
Lotus and just to heat things up even
more Megan captioned the post sizzly
Sicily sounds like these rumors won't be
stopping anytime soon